what did the poster and trailers reveal
about jordan peel's nope are aliens
truly involved there are still a lot of
questions to be answered so watch this
before you see nope last year on july
22nd 2021 jordan peele took to twitter
to release the new poster and title of
his upcoming film revealing that nope
would be released exactly one year from
the davis announcement now that release
date is fast approaching peel remained
tight-lipped about the movie for most of
the year including just a cloud emoji
with a poster revealed production took
place in june of 2021 and star kiki
palmer revealed that filming took place
in santa clarita california nope has
quite the cast to begin with the three
leads appear to be daniel kaluuya kiki
palmer and steven young kaluyo's
breakout role was none other than get
out for which his stunning performance
earned an oscar nomination for best
actor since then he's been appearing in
notable films left and right such as
black panther and judas and the black
messiah the latter of which earned him
his first oscar win meanwhile palmer
made waves for her supporting role in
2019's hustlers and also for her work in
the lead role in 2022's alice and
finally yen also received an oscar
nomination for his starring turn in
menari kaluya and palmer play siblings
oj and emerald haywood who own a ranch
in the first trailer emerald describes
him as the only black-owned horse
trainers in hollywood hen plays ricky
juke park who from the two released
trailers seems to be some sort of rodeo
announcer additionally the supporting
cast includes euphoria breakout barbie
ferreira the oa cast member brandon
perea and michael wincott from westworld
up until recently the plot of knope has
been kept under wraps even the first
trailer which was released in february
didn't tell us much besides the fact
that the ranch owners oj and emerald
began noticing alien-like objects in the
sky the eerie first trailer promises a
horror-filled movie going experience but
not much else specifically with the
second trailer we finally have a bit
more insight into the plot of nope it
seems as though oj and emerald began
experiencing weird potentially alien
related encounters after the mysterious
death of their father after o.j tells
emerald that he saw a very large object
above the clouds emerald asks if it
might have something to do with the
unexplained violence
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
then after witnessing the ominous
objects in the sky themselves the
siblings decide to try and capture the
moments on film to gain fame and fortune
once they provide proof of aliens they
even hire a tech-minded assistant angel
torres who works for fry's electronics
to help them out as well as a mysterious
man named antlers holst whom emerald
claims is the only person who is capable
of getting the strange invaders on film
even though the second trailer feels a
bit more lighthearted than the first we
can definitely expect horror to be at
the center of the story the first
official trailer for jordan peele's
upcoming film knope opens with edward
murray bridges the horse in motion
followed by emerald hayward's narration
about its significance as the first film
ever made she follows up by claiming
that she and her brother are related to
the writer and the short we then find
out that she is filming an advertisement
for her and her brother oj's hollywood
horse training services afterward we see
quick snippets of strange occurrences
happening around the small rural
california area where the horse training
stable resides this includes inflatable
wavy tube men deflating ominous shadows
enveloping everything and animals
freaking out it also seems to confirm
early rumors that the film will be about
aliens or at the very least otherworldly
creatures in some capacity midway
through the trailer there is what looks
like an alien hand outstretched towards
a human child's fist seemingly a direct
reference to e.t the extraterrestrial
right afterward there is a strange
looking creature scurrying in the
darkness obscured by shadows and fences
that appears to be chasing one of the
main characters as not to mention kaluya
riding on horseback is a shadow engulfs
the scenery like the saucers in
independence day and an abduction seeing
a palmer at the very end of the trailer
the second trailer further confirms the
alien invasion storyline with several
more shots of ufos flying through the
sky it even ends with oj bling on
horseback from a silver flying saucer
all jordan peel's titles are evocative
in one way or another get out was very
apt evoking racist messages along the
lines of get out of my neighborhood that
have been levied against black people in
the past meanwhile us refers to both the
connections between the characters and
their antagonistic doppelgangers as well
as us as an abbreviation for the united
states nope however might be the most
cryptic title so far some fans have
speculated that it might have to do with
the acronym n-o-p-e which would
supposedly stand for not of planet earth
it's above us writer director jordan
peele himself however has a different
interpretation stating in an interview
with entertainment weekly
this film is definitely a ride the title
speaks to the idea of being in tune with
what the audience is thinking and
feeling in the theater i know a lot of
people who say when it's a scary movie
they say nope especially black audiences
right we love horror but there's a
skepticism besides the posters and
trailers there's also a viral video for
nope that surfaced a while ago on jordan
peel's official twitter account it was
made to look like someone recording a
local news broadcast which reported on a
flood of yellow-headed blackbirds in
mexico falling out of the sky for some
mysterious reason since the film's
trailer shows horses getting spooked by
some unseen force it makes sense that
this force could be affecting other
animals like birds as well there is a
similar scene in m night shyamalan's
signs in which birds are killed in
mid-air by an unseen force in the case
of signs the birds crashed into cloaked
spaceships the reporter in the video
ends a broadcast by hypothesizing about
what the birds might be fleeing from
some experts say the blackbirds may have
been trying to escape a predatory bird
or perhaps they were attacked by a
spacecraft only time will tell for sure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
no for coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you